il ne serait non pas un mais deux selon
de nouveaux éléments de l'enquète deux
impliqués dans la fusillade place
saint-paul à tour le tireur accompagné
d'une autre personne qui conduisait le
scooter
les auteurs sont toujours en fuite hier
vers 14 heures un homme d'une vingtaine
d'années circulent à pied devant ce bar
lorsque le deux roues s'arrête à
quelques mètres de lui
deux coups de feu sont tirés par miracle
la victime n'est que légèrement blessé à
la cuisse il a déjà quitté l'hôpital
trousseau
un autre homme attablé au bar a quant à
lui reçu des éclats de verre lorsque la
vitrine a explosé comme nous l'évoquions
hier la thèse du règlement de comptes
est privilégiée
règlement de comptes entre dealers et
consommateurs avance une source
syndicale
la victime était déjà connu des services
de police la police judiciaire et le
commissariat de tours ont été cosaisis
de l'enquète si la thèse du règlement de
compte était confirmé il s'agirait du
deuxième en l'espace de six mois dans le
quartier du sanitas fin décembre un
trafiquant de stupéfiants de 19 ans
avait réchappé une attaque à l arme de
poing il avait reçu trois balles dans le
corps